al contar de cinco en cinco empezando en
385 que en números de 10 elige todas las
opciones correctas y aquí están las
opciones que nos muestran para saber
cuáles son las que tenemos que elegir
tenemos que saber cuáles son los números
que a partir de este vamos a obtener
contando de cinco en cinco así que
tenemos nuestros 385 y a éste le tenemos
que agregar un 5 esto es igual
5 5 es 10 tenemos ser unidades llevamos
una decena a este 8 le sumamos esa
decena que nos quedó que eran 9 y el 3
queda igual que era 390 este es el
primer número que nos queda y ahora es
790 también le vamos a sumar un 5
estamos contando de 55 390 más 5 95 95
el 300 se quede igual 395
está muy sencillo porque voy a estar
terminando en cero o en cinco vamos a
seguirlo haciendo ahora al 395 le sumó 5
es como el primero 55 me da 10 tengo
aquí cero unidades
llevo una decena y esa decena se la sumó
a estas nueve decenas al 9 + 1 nos da
también 10 pero ahora aquí pongo 0 de
escenas porque ya tengo una centena ese
es el tema se le sumó a este 3 que
representa 303 centenas 3 más 14 aquí ya
tengo 400 ahora tomamos el 400 y le
sumamos 5 aquí ya está más sencillo más
directo 400 más 5 405 ahora sumamos al
405 que acabamos de obtener otros 5 55
10 aquí no tengo otras decenas así que
escribo directamente el 10 una decena
será unidades y nuestras centenas estas
cuatro centenas de 400
410 vamos a ver qué opciones tenemos
aquí esta primera opción es 390 y veo
que si aquí tengo el 390 esta es una
opción que elegiría
las siguientes 392 pues no aquí no tengo
un 392 tengo 395 y aquí está en esta
tercera opción 395 aquí está este luego
sigue aquí 400 vemos en nuestros
resultados y si aquí está 400 está
también la seleccionamos la siguiente
opción 403 vemos aquí pues no no tenemos
403 la siguiente 405 ésta sí aquí la
tengo esta también está y está la
selección
tengo aquí 410 y efectivamente también
encontré este número todos estos los he
encontrado este le seleccionó y
finalmente tengo el 411 que aquí no lo
tengo y si yo quisiera ver si el
siguiente número de 410 contando de
cinco en cinco cuales pues tengo 410 a
esto le sumó 5 y que me va a dar 05
unidades me quedan cinco unidades no
tengo más decenas me quedan estas
decenas o una decena y las centenas me
quedan las cuatro me queda el 400 415 y
vemos que este 415 pues es mayor que el
414 no es igual así que están ahora
selecciona y con esto ya tengo resuelto
el problema